the report accuses the metropolitan
police
of a form of institutional corruption
police corruption is a betrayal of
everything policing stands for in this
country
it erodes public confidence in our
entire criminal justice system
it undermines democracy and civilized
society
we look to the police to protect us and
so they are invested with great power
the overwhelming majority of officers
use it honorably
but those who use their power for
immoral lens
do terrible harm as do those who indulge
cover up or ignore police corruption
this is one of the most devastating
episodes in the history of the
metropolitan police
in recent years mr speaker several steps
have been taken to combat police
corruption
a new offence of police corruption
solely applicable to police officers
was introduced by my right honourable
friend the member for maidenhead in 2015
to assist alongside the existing
offences of misconduct in public office
the offence carries a maximum prison
sentence of 14 years
to prevent corrupt officers evade and
accountability by resigning or retiring
the police in and crimac 2017
enabled the extension of disciplinary
procedures to former officers
it also ensures that if an officer under
investigation for gross misconduct
resigns or retires misconduct
proceedings can still take place
and the officer can be barred from
rejoining the police
last year mr speaker i overhauled the
police complaints and discipline process
there is now a more efficient system for
dealing with police misconduct
the investigation process is simpler and
quicker
and an explanation is required if an
investigation takes longer than 12
months
it is in the interest of both the police
and the public that corrupt police
officers are exposed
and innocent ones exonerated as swiftly
as possible
the group of states against corruption
monitors countries compliance with the
council of europe's anti-corruption
standards
and this month it published a report
demonstrating good progress in the uk's
law enforcement to prevent corruption
but mr speaker we cannot ignore the
findings of this report
its recommendations are wide-ranging and
far-reaching
across aspects of policing conduct
culture and transparency in public
institutions
today i have written today cressida dick
to ask her to provide me with a detailed
response into the panel's
recommendations for the metropolitan
police
and the wider issues outlined within the
report
this afternoon i will also ask her
majesty's inspectorate of constabulary
and fire and rescue services to consider
how best it can look into the issues
raised
the police mr speaker are operationally
independent
and the metropolitan police are held to
account by the mayor of london
and the mayor's office for policing and
crime
but the police are accountable to
parliament through me
i intend to return to the house to
update on progress made on this and
other recommendations made in the report
once i have received responses from the
metropolitan police and others
mr speaker there can be no confidence in
the integrity of policing
without confidence in the police
watchdog
the iopc has made good progress since it
was formed in 2018
but questions remain about its ability
to hold the police to account
in particular profound concerns exist
around the handling of the iopc's
investigation into operation midland
the issues raised by daniel morgan's
independent panel further reinforce the
need for a strong
police watchdog i'm therefore announcing
today that i'm bringing forward the next
periodic review of the iopc to start
this summer
this will include an assessment of the
iopc's effectiveness and deficiency
mr speaker daniel morgan deserved far
far better than this
as did his family and to them on what
will be a very very difficult day
i say that the whole house will have
them and daniel
in our thoughts i commend this statement
to the house